Here are 14 basic movie genres: which are your favorite?
One: Action, Disaster:...
...stories whose central struggle plays out mainly through a clash of physical forces.
Two: Adventure.
The central struggle plays out mainly through encounters with new "worlds."
Three: Comedy: The plot causes hilarious results.
Four: Coming-of-Age Drama.
Stories about the hero finding his or her place in the world.
Five: Crime: The central struggle is about catching a criminal.
Six: Detective Story, Courtroom Drama.
The plot is to find out what really happened and thus to expose the truth.
Seven: Epic, Myth.
The central struggle plays out in the midst of a clash of great forces...
...or in the sweep of great historical change.
Eight: Fantasy.
Animated stories or whose central struggle plays out in two worlds,...
...the real world and an imaginary world.
Nine: Gangster: The plot centers on a criminal and society.
A cautionary tale,...
...rooted in a main character that commits crimes and is often blended with Film Noir.
Ten: Horror.
The hero focuses on escaping from and eventually defeating a human or non-human monster.
Eleven: Love, Romance.
The plot centers on two people wanting to win or keep the love of the other.
Twelve: Science Fiction.
The plot is generated from the technology and tools of a scientifically imaginable world.
Thirteen: Social Drama: The plot centers on a champion...
...and a problem or injustice in society...
...with the champion having a personal stake in the outcome.
Fourteen: Thriller.
The plot pits an innocent hero against a lethal enemy trying to kill him or her.